when Musa regains consciousness the West
Side boys are taking the patrol deeper
into the jungle late that afternoon they
arrived at the rebel stronghold a tiny
village called kaberi Bona rebel leader
Foday Kallay sees the 12 men as hostile
intruders I'm not the one give the order
to arrest them both my men Iris DeMent
and avoid him to me they note up any
business to go out in a jungle together
as his spy he knows the British soldiers
will be invaluable bargaining chips as
hostages they'll give the west side boys
power and maybe a way out of the jungle
now
50 kilometers away in Freetown senior
officers from the Royal Irish Rangers
enjoy a drink
an urgent message arrives 12 men are
missing a chill runs through leftenant
Colonel Simon Fordham the regiment's
commanding officer in Sierra Leone we
surmised that they had an accident or
the worst case would be that somehow
they had been they got involved with the
west side boys or been apprehended by
the British commanders immediately plan
a full-scale search but Musa fears his
time is already running out hey Miguel
and Michelle this is a real messy
situation these guys making any time T
now I am not important to them I'm not
going to be abandon ship
maybe my days over
minutes later the rebels dragged him
away
he's beaten again this time by toy
soldiers
I was feeling to be everything because
we got bitten everywhere my head my eyes
my every he's thrown into an old cess
pit
his cell is 2 meters deep and about five
meters square the stench is unbearable
there's nothing to drink